she's an exceptionally talented person
in many different spaces she's a special
one that was g-e-z back in october
gushing about his then-girlfriend ashley
benson to e.t
now a source tells e.t the two have
called it quits
after less than a year together quote
g-eazy really enjoys being in
relationships and likes the idea of
having a girlfriend
but his relationship with ashley was
becoming a bit too domestic for his
liking
and that was one of the reasons they
broke up now that their relationship is
over
he's looking forward to being single it
is what it is
it's unclear exactly when the split
occurred but the source says that the
rapper is embracing the single life
he's also been working on new music and
he's looking forward to this new era
both professionally and personally
back in october the 31 year old musician
opened up about his relationship with a
pretty little liar star for the first
time
and couldn't help but rave over his then
love whom he's worked with
on several songs she's an exceptionally
talented person
in many different spaces she's a special
one she
has you know obviously she's a great
actress
but you know getting to work with her
and putting a printer putting her in
front of a microphone and watching her
sing so effortlessly and
she has this very special tone of voice
and texture and something that's very
innate to her given that it's not her
you know it's not her like first you
know job or what she's known
for it just blew me away that you could
have such a hidden
you know special talent that the world
doesn't you know get to see as often
okay so these two might not be together
anymore but we
might just get some bops from the
heartbreak g-eazy who also dated halsey
told et that he's not afraid to let
painful past
experiences fuel his music i've
experienced
love in my life and i've experienced
heartbreak in my life
and i caused heartbreak in my life and i
received heartbreak in my life
and you know the power of music is to
kind of express and capture
the human experience you know we live
and we experience things and then
music for us is you know as an outlet as
a way to
to channel that you know the things that
we go through and put it into some
tangible form